her name is hava even english and she's
just entered a world full of hope and
uncertainty
her afghan parents were evacuated from
kabul to dubai where they caught a
turkish airlines flight to the uk helped
by the cabin crew her mom soman had to
give birth on board
as havor arrived the british military
confirmed it was ending its flights
carrying civilians france has done the
same
shakiba an afghan actress living in
france managed to get her mother and
brother out of afghanistan at the last
minute as in so many cases it involved
days of frantic phone calls to people on
the ground at the airport
i've rediscovered the smell of my mother
and it's something that i'd forgotten
my mother's tears reminded me of the
tears she shed when i left afghanistan
it was really moving
a lot of emotions today
shabir an afghan journalist filmed
himself as he and nine close relatives
waited to get onto one of the final
evacuation flights he's now in spain
spending night and day in the airport
and the gate was one of the worst
experiences i have ever had i never
uh was forced to spend the night
uh with my family um in an open place
like that with thousands of people
not in the worst
days of afghanistan
shapiro and his family are now seeking
asylum but the british government admits
up to 1100 afghans eligible to be
resettled in the uk mainly because they
worked with british troops are being
left behind the head of the uk armed
forces says it's heartbreaking
personally i've probably had
over 100 messages from different afghans
who i know in my long association with
the country and many of those
friends of mine won't make it out
at this small organization near london
they're scrambling to help people still
trying to get out of afghanistan their
founder says it's clear there are many
still in danger
the british government should
act immediately in order to save the
life of other thousands of other people
who
been working
for the past 20 years supporting the
nato mission
as these afghan civilians arrived in
rome a nato representative said his team
had done everything they could
unsatisfied because
we have left a few behind which we are
not abandoning
but
which we will strive our best to take
back home
as the sun sets on the military
evacuations the question now is how many
more people who fear for their lives
will be able to leave afghanistan and
how
nadeem baba al jazeera